ah here are some words and phrases to
make you sound smarter semantic
satiation when you say or read a word so
many times that it stops making sense
dysphemism use of a negative term for
something positive sick moves bro sunder
the sudden realization that everyone
around you is living a life is vivid and
complex as your own
Yanik describes something shaped like a
vagina susurrus a whispering or rustling
sound lacunae a non-english word that
describes something for which there is
no english word such as mo jude's
exactly the right word or expression for
a situation proprietary eponym a
trademark or brand name that has become
a generic name for a product or service
de nominalization using a word that is
not a verb as a verb
contrastive focus reduplication a
repeated adjective used for emphasis I
mean the film is interesting but not
interesting interesting or allies like
visualizing with sound
let the Logica inability to articulate a
thought
due to forgetting a key word phrase or
name I'm I'm a dunning-kruger effect
when someone is so incompetent that they
believe they are exceptionally skilled
I'm Dee Roberts and I'm a master of
espanol yo soy el baño del mundo nestle
lapel du vide the urge to jump from a
high place while encountering a high
place
now get out there and be sesquipedalian